[Music]
was our first feature of Point Break did
we do that before rumors not officially
yet right so as a company tremors would
be the first technically the future
gasps I don't know
someone should Google that are you going
to ask us questions or do you want us to
start talking did you introduce each
other I would love to I would like to
introduce you to Tom Woodruff jr. who's
the co-founder of amalgamated dynamics
I'd like to introduce you to Alec Gillis
he's the co-founder of Adi home of the
oscar-winning creature effects team when
people think of practical effects
creatures you think of non
computer-generated characters we've been
lucky to be involved with some of the
biggest at best of those types of
monsters we did the worms and tremors we
did the fat makeups of Tim Allen in the
Santa Clause all the practical animals
in Jumanji we've done the alien we've
done the predator with our ship troopers
I wasn't done you can keep going buddy
and of course there's always the gorilla
cut right now that's perfect right now
we cut putting the gorilla costume
we started performing own creatures
because we both had his sort of
observation of stuntmen
despite their talents and their skills
them going into a creature suit and not
really knowing how to make a creature
suit work it would be very weird for us
to just say we're gonna build something
and then bring it to set and say now
what are you hungry that's some food you
hungry you're a digital animator you
build the character and you follow
through and you make it move and you
bring
to life so that's our philosophy is the
final step is performance because that's
where it lives you want to try a little
tiny piece here go ahead what do you
think you want some more hey listen
listen I can get you fresh bread
I can I can get you fresh bread tremors
is an example of a film that was from
the pre-digital era and if you look at
it the practical effects they've stood
the test of time and we're proud of that
digital effects can do things that we
can't possibly do practical effects have
a presence to them that even the best
CGI work gets close to but doesn't
completely achieve in other words
there's more emotion I believe to a
practical creature than to a digital
creature
wave to the camera and say goodbye bye
bye he's so temperamental this is a
billion dollars we think and that
billion dollars belongs to RJ Rappaport
and he's considered the king of cash
fake cash okay
king of fake cash my name is rich r.j.
Rappaport and I'm the president of RJR
props just a few years ago actually it
was nine years ago
oh sorry nine years ago RJ R props was
born it's a full-service prop house but
its specialty is cash think cash and
there's only a few people who can
legally make it and RJ is one of them
[Music]
we work with 50 cent Kendrick Lamar
Lil Wayne Fat Joe Young Dolph and that's
just to name a few
RJ's prop money has been used in over
175 feature films television shows and
music videos and he devoted three full
years to perfecting that crisp green
paper we call money prop money and we
went down a long path and working with
the Secret Service and learning all the
laws to make sure that everyone that
uses it it will be legal for them and
it'll look fantastic but for those who
don't follow the rules they could wind
up in big trouble there is a rash of
arrests people were just literally
jailed because they were using prop
money that looked too real and I said to
myself I'm not gonna touch this unless I
know I'm doing it legally alongside the
Secret Service
RJ created two different styles of prop
money one that is printed on both sides
and is perfect for that classic bank
robbery scene the other kind is so close
to the real deal it can only be printed
on one side otherwise it could end up in
circulation
it's designed for the classic money shot
aka this the close-up it's a tough
business we all work hard in it and prop
money especially it's not easy yeah
sounds like it
thanks RJ for keeping fake money real
[Music]
we usually get up about 7:00 and I
usually get up a little later I make
coffee for both of us I like honey and
cream and I copy and then I almost
always drive to work our morning routine
is quite Monday oh yeah one thing we're
doing today is a fire-breathing dragon
finishing off that yeah and I've got
some stuff to blood and some skulls and
pumpkins I'm Marsha this is my husband
Edie
and we run distortions unlimited we make
monsters zombies aliens dragons and
beasts of all kinds
oh my most of what we make is scary I
will say that we make monsters for
everyone from home Haunter all the way
up to amusement parks and big events all
around the world we've been working
together for 35 years it's been glorious
yeah wonderful
[Music]
we started out painting together I fell
in love very quickly we've been married
almost 25 years we've found a way to
work together I'm probably more on the
business side and it is probably more in
the production I can't tell you how many
people have told me I could never work
with my spouse and that's too bad
because you miss half or more of that
whole person's life if you don't
[Music]
I think people expect us to be a little
bit weirder than yarn we're actually a
little bit boring when we get in the car
and go home it's over
we love monsters we just we've had
enough of it after a long day there's a
separation there there has to be you'd
go crazy if somebody walked into our
house they wouldn't have a clue what we
do in fact we keep it all kind of secret
yeah people are surprised about that
with us we like it that way
it's really special to do something you
love with somebody you love we make
monsters but whatever our personalities
kind of mesh with each other so it works
out you know you really can establish a
good relationship as you're dripping
zombie blood that's the kind of woman I
need in my life
[Music]
when you're watching a television show
or a movie and you see an actor holding
a magazine or book or a letter
a lot of what you're seeing on the
screen was custom-made by people like me
let me see their paperwork
if I've done my job right in creating
that piece of paper the possibilities
are literally endless I mean one single
piece of paper can communicate a huge
amount in telling the audience about the
character or about the scene
[Applause]
it's figuring out how this thing can
best do its job of being a part of the
story
[Music]
my name is Ross McDonald and I create
paper props for movies and television
when I was a kid I was obsessed with
comics was obsessed with paper and
illustration and really loved that world
that I was reading or seeing on paper
I've done a little bit of everything for
years I worked as a magazine a newspaper
illustrator book illustrator that
eventually led me into making props for
the last 25 years I've made tens of
thousands of paper props for close to 50
television shows and movies my first
major motion picture was babies day out
and I was hired basically as an
illustrator to illustrate a Pho 1930s
children's book I've done literally tens
of thousands of props for all five
seasons Boardwalk Empire I did the
Pawnee charter for an episode of Parks
and Recreation for joy I did all of the
patents for the mops that we see played
I did yoga secrets for The Wizard of
lies
I've designed everything from passports
and maps and travel documents wanted
posters government forms FBI reports
psychiatric files agent identification
folders anything gets made of paper I
made at one time or another part of what
you need to figure out when you're
making a paper prop is the backstory of
the piece of paper you don't just take a
new book and slosh brown ink on to make
it look old you got to figure out how it
got worn how it got dirty the scene
might involve an actor reading three
lines out of a letter but you have to
figure out how old is it what kind of
paper isn't made out of how was the
paper made should it be made with carbon
paper should it be on onion skin some
guy gonna pull out a ruffled piece of
paper from his pocket or is he gonna
pull it out of a file folder what color
paper should it be sure to be yellow
should it be white should it be ivory
colored who's signing it what does their
handwriting look like what kind of ink
are they using when they write it what
kind of pen are they using and then
because no letter is ever three lines
you have to write the rest of the copy
in the letter depending on what I'm
making a project can take you know a day
an hour weeks months every page is
filled out every book has text on it and
pictures every paper in the file folder
is is a real document that's all filled
out and created for example for the book
of secrets they said just come up with
secrets so I said okay well let's do
Roswell let's do the Kennedy
assassination let's do all these crazy
conspiracy theory things then there was
the research into those specific things
you have to find all that figure out how
to recreate it convincingly it was a
huge undertaking it took about four
months to really build that prop and
it's just communicated in a split second
in the scene have you seen the evening
paper I have here pieces of paper
there's so many amazing things that
start off with a piece of paper and the
props that I'm making they're all part
of that sometimes when they go to the
theater I'm so excited I'm almost
shaking and it's not because I want to
see the driver's license I made from one
of the actors it's because I I did a
tiny bit of work on that movie and it's
that's very exciting to me in the end
you've produced this thing which you
know you've done your best job of
nailing getting absolutely right and you
know sometimes I'm just like wow you see
something like that in the final product
and realize that this thing you've
worked on is this huge moment in the
story that can be just really really a
great family
[Music]